[Music]
ever since the first astronaut went to
space almost 60 years ago over 500
people have blasted out of Earth's
atmosphere they lived and worked in
space at different times but nobody's
ever been born there what if you were
the first space baby to be carried
aboard a space station
how would your young body develop in
microgravity and would you be able to
visit your relatives on planet earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were born on a space
station so what's so different about
being born in space anyway no gravity
well in fact gravity on the
International Space Station is about 90
percent as strong as it is on the
surface of the earth so why do we see
astronauts floating around inside it
that's because they're actually falling
let me explain
Earth's gravity is pulling the ISS down
but the ISS is moving very fast at the
same speed that the Earth's surface is
turning underneath it the space station
is constantly falling to earth but will
never hit it the freefall is what causes
microgravity making the astronauts float
around so what would it be like to be
born weightless before we get to the
birth part let us just say nobody's ever
had sexual intercourse on a space
station let alone made a baby it
wouldn't be any kind of
out-of-this-world experience
fluids work differently in microgravity
you may not have the blood flow to get
you or your partner aroused sweat would
build up around your body making it wet
and sticky all over and that's if you
could figure out how not to push your
partner away upon contact conceiving a
child would be a whole other problem in
addition to a low gravity environment
there's also so much radiation in space
that it can affect a man's sperm count
possibly even cause infertility and we
don't even know exactly what kind of
changes space conditions would cause to
a human embryo let's imagine your
pregnant mother arrived on a space
station to give birth to you the trip to
space alone would be hard enough on your
mother pushing you out of her body
without the help of gravity wouldn't be
a piece of cake either if you made it
out of the womb a low gravity
environment would affect your body
systems as you grew up
including your muscular development and
eyesight
when grown-up astronauts work aboard the
space station their bone density
depletes at a rate of one percent per
month because it takes no effort to
float in space they also tend to lose
muscle strength now since there's no way
to force a baby to run on a treadmill to
keep its muscles forming as you grew on
the space station your skeleton might
become deformed your heart would be weak
as it's never had to work against
Earth's gravity then there's space
radiation it would increase the
probability of cancer dysfunction of the
heart and central nervous system and
eyesight problems if after surviving all
that you made the trip to earth you
wouldn't be able to walk or balance
properly you might also struggle trying
to interact with people on earth since
you grew up crammed into a very small
space your whole life until somebody
invents a gravity polarizer to generate
artificial gravity fields on a space
station we probably shouldn't think
about having babies in space but once
they do how long do you think it would
take for us to become a galactic
civilization that's a question for
another what-if
[Music]